what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some news about Doctor
Strange making his return to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we have a direct
update from Benedict Cumberbatch himself
the actor who plays Doctor Strange he
was recently on a show where he talked
very little about doctor strange but he
did briefly mention that he is about to
start his return to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now this doesn't really come as
too big of a surprise it was reported
not too long ago that doctor strange 3
would have to take place at least before
Avengers Secret Wars possibly even
before Avengers the King Dynasty which
makes perfect sense because in the
post-credit scene for Doctor Strange and
the Multiverse of Madness or Doctor
Strange 2 we saw that CLIA appeared and
told doctor strange that he created an
incursion and that they were going to
fix it and that is basically the whole
premise of the latter half of the
Multiverse Saga incursions happening in
the Multiverse being at risk of complete
and total Destruction so it doesn't even
make sense for Doctor Strange 3 to come
out after the Multiverse Saga because
incursions will at least we hope be
taken care of by then or the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as we know it will
completely change and then it'll kind of
be irrelevant as it is incursions won't
really matter at least not for a while
they are the main premise for the King
Dynasty and Secret Wars now we do know
that doctor strange 3 is going to be
coming before Avengers Secret Wars
however we aren't actually sure that
this update that Benedict Cumberbatch
has given us is for Doctor Strange three
it could be for another movie that
doctor strange could be in and the other
movies that he could possibly be in are
equally exciting because they could mean
some pretty epic crossovers like
possibly Doctor Strange appearing in the
Fantastic Four movie and we'll dive into
why he could be talking about the
Fantastic Four movie in just a bit let's
first go over what exactly he said when
appearing on the show ah
jw3 speaker series series he was talking
about the upcoming projects that he
would be filming as an actor and he said
there are some Marvel capers in the
making next year confirming that he is
either going to start filming next year
for a role as Doctor Strange or he will
come out in something next year as
Doctor Strange now since we haven't
heard anything about him appearing in
any of the upcoming Marvel movies or
shows it's more than likely that he is
talking about starting to film something
next year for something that he will
appear in however there is a possibility
that he could show up in some movies
next year like perhaps Deadpool 3.
that's going to be a Multiverse
traveling movie in which it will
directly affect the Multiverse and
incursions we already know Deadpool is
going to cause incursions to happen in
fact we've already seen him do it in the
post credits for Deadpool 3 he stole
Cable's time travel device and already
changed a lot and they're going to
address that and deal with that in
Deadpool 3. so perhaps Doctor Strange
makes an appearance but again since he
was talking about next year that that
most likely means that he would have
already had to film his role for
Deadpool 3 or we'll have to do it really
soon and there has been no word about
that and nobody has seen him on set the
other possible project could be Agatha
coven of chaos but again this has pretty
much all been filmed already unless they
decide to come back and do some reshoots
and again no sign of him on the set for
Agatha no word at all about him being in
this project so we are looking towards
the future and many people right now are
looking at the Fantastic Four and if we
break it down it really does seem to
make sense but of course he could simply
be coming back for Dr Strange 3 just
because we haven't heard anything about
when it's going to film or when it's
going to possibly release doesn't mean
that it's not in the plans for Marvel
Studios they could just be keeping it
very secret right now so of course this
could be for Doctor Strange 3 however
the Fantastic Four already does have a
release date right now it's coming May
2nd of 2025. that means they could start
filming for this movie late next year
and again if we think about the events
that place and Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness it would make
sense for him to appear at least even if
for a brief moment in the Fantastic Four
film especially if you consider what is
going to happen immediately after the
Fantastic Four film which is the events
of the King Dynasty and then Avengers
Secret Wars now the Fantastic Four film
is definitely going to be somewhat of an
origin story It's Gonna Be An Origin
story of them in the MCU meaning they're
going to make their debut in the MCU but
Kevin feige the president of Marvel
Studios has basically already confirmed
this isn't going to be a traditional
origin story for the Fantastic Four this
is sort of what they did for Spider-Man
and Spider-Man homecoming they didn't do
the classic Peter gets bit by a
radioactive spider Uncle Ben dies that
classic origin story that we've seen
many times which is why Kevin feige
stated they didn't do it because we've
seen it many times already and at this
point we do know the origin of the
Fantastic Four it's been adapted a few
times it doesn't mean they won't show An
Origin at all he just said not a
traditional one so don't get me wrong
the movie is going to focus on the
Fantastic Four however let's not forget
that in Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness Doctor Strange met a read
Richards of a different universe and
they referred to him as the smartest man
alive and he was a part of a super group
that universe's Avengers Doctor Strange
was asking what do you have the Avengers
is it Shield who am I going to and they
said the Illuminati and he did not know
who that was so now that doctor strange
is back in the main Universe it would
make sense for him to investigate some
of these characters that he saw in the
other Universe especially since there
was another superhero group in charge
Doctor Strange is in charge of
protecting our main universe's reality
and he is a very curious person so it is
in line with his character to go and
investigate if these characters actually
exist in his universe is there a
Professor Xavier is there a Black Bolt
is there a smartest man alive that goes
by Reed Richards who is a part of the
Fantastic Four or in his own universe
but to take it a step even further read
Richards in the secret Wars comics plays
a huge role especially when it comes to
restoring the broken Multiverse that is
something that we are going to need in
the MCU and Doctor Strange is going to
have to realize this and the two of them
are probably going to realize it on
their own and come together read
Richards as the smartest man alive will
understand how the science of incursions
actually happens in Doctor Strange will
understand kind of the whole magical
Multiverse side of it so the two of them
are going to be pretty key characters
coming up and if they just throw us the
Fantastic Four and dive right into the
multiversal problems in the film then it
would make sense for Doctor Strange to
find Reed Richards maybe just a quick
little Cameo popping up and saying read
Richards I need your help to save the
Multiverse this is pretty much what he
did with Tony Stark in Avengers Infinity
War he popped up in a portal in the park
when Tony and pepper were running and
essentially said yo I'm Doctor Strange I
need your help I can see him doing this
to read Richards but of course there are
other movies that he could possibly pop
up in like blade it's a supernatural
movie Doctor Strange does fall in the
Supernatural side of the MCU and if the
midnight Suns really are going to be
formed in the MCU which we have been
told by some insiders that that is
indeed going to happen that would make
sense that doctor strange would start to
form the midnight Suns and of course we
cannot forget about Spider-Man there are
some unresolved things between Peter
Parker and Doctor Strange now Doctor
Strange might not know that Peter Parker
is Spider-Man but he still remembers and
knows of Spider-Man and it would make
sense for him to appear in Spider-Man 4
especially if the spell is going to be
undone in some way shape or form or
perhaps Peter Parker misses MJ so much
that he wants her to remember him so he
goes to Doctor Strange we know Zendaya
is returning for Spider-Man 4 so this is
a possibility but given the fact that
doctor strange played a huge role in the
last Spider-Man film would make it
pretty easy for him to show up in the
next Spider-Man which is expected to
come out either before the King Dynasty
or right after which could mean they
could start filming sometime next year
so there are many options for Doctor
Strange to appear in the MCU it could be
doctor strange 3 that would be probably
the most logical thing to think about
but it also could be the Fantastic Four
as well and there are definitely other
projects where he could show up that
makes sense but let us know your
thoughts about this where do you think
he's going to show up in another project
or do you think it's going to be for
Doctor Strange three let us know your
thoughts in the comments down below also
don't forget to subscribe to stay up to
date on the MCU and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items we pick a
winner at the end of each month and the
winner gets to pick one item you can
also follow us on Instagram and Twitter
as well and if you want you can check
out our patreon our Discord server and
our website as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf